is this like one two three or like one
two three go
okay this is whatever you what does that
mean will you marry me happy birthday
[Music]
two singles will experience a simulation
of the first four stages of a so-called
traditional relationship date move in
marriage baby each stage comes with a
challenge if they succeed they receive
an advantage to help them in the next
round in the end they'll decide if a
lifetime of love will lead to a second
date hi I'm Jess I am 33 years old and I
work in legal cannabis sales my name is
Tomas de Massimo I'm 26 years old and I
guess I'm a film student I have been
single for a little over a year now I've
been single about a year I really like
musicians and artists curvy oh so sorry
it's my song
physical type um my roommate would say
that I like guys who look like
Lumberjacks having like a good phone
voice I don't know that does a lot for
me like sounded sexy on the phone very
liberal
maybe a little socialist you're like a
Republican or something like yeah don't
even it's really hard to explain but
y'all should Google Hyperion ISM yeah I
do believe in God Mama's boys are a big
no hard no never ever ever no ever ever
no yeah definitely hardcore moms Rock
hot always hot summer always summer why
not both cats and dogs dogs I like
coffee and tea see how you doing this
would be so awkward if we know each
other you know I had that thought hello
hello I'm Jess I'm Tommy nice to meet
you nice to meet you he immediately
reminded me of my younger brother who I
adore but would never date she seems
like very wise right away maybe this is
like all the Rings and stones it is that
like a stone or something this is an
arrowhead
I believe it's obsidian does it do
anything if you want to believe it does
it does the couple is on their first
date they have ten minutes to draw a
portrait of each other doing an
activity they think their partner enjoys
if correct they receive an advantage in
the next challenge I just want to go
ahead and apologize for the strong of
you and that's okay this is already not
going well I apologize if my drawing
makes you feel bad about your drawing so
I don't know if you've read the book on
the five love languages do you know what
yours are if you have probably like
access service what's yours I like
giving things quality time is extremely
important do you feel like this is
quality time right now um sure I mean
it's not something I would usually do
just on account if I don't drink but oh
you don't drink alcohol at all no oh do
you have a problem with alcohol no I
just feel like it just isn't a healthy
drug for people to use what kind of
sense of humor do you have terrible
I don't like videos of people like
tripping and falling and stuff like that
I guess that's pretty pretty lowbrow cuz
they just have no idea that's coming a
little cruel yeah why you know it life
is uh life's a little cruel if you look
at it that way I suppose okay
so this is this is an expressionistic
war work of you this is you digging for
obsidian and it's s meant to symbolize
like your journey for you know your
spiritual self
you're digging deep into a quarry of
obsidian he actually did a lot better
than I expected it wasn't a stick figure
so you did put some effort into it this
is Tommy playing video games does she
think I'm like I don't know some like
dude sitting in his boxers eating
Cheetos playing video games all day cuz
like I'm not a fly I was a little shady
you like she made my beard like not
filling all the way beards and my beard
it's pretty full so I think this is a
pretty accurate image of me I'm not
against geology in terms of like the
spiritual growth and all that stuff like
the metaphorical level I don't know you
kind of just threw that out there
but yeah that's kind of my my [ __ ] the
couple is moving in together they have
ten minutes to build a stepstool because
they won the last reward they're given
instructions finish in time and they'll
receive an advantage in the next stage
let's make this effective mmm these
bubbling out or in in you knew right
where to look that would have taken me a
long way so what makes you a bad
roommate
I like personal space I just after a
while I'm like okay I need to not see
your face I am NOT gonna disagree with
it if I ever live with someone again I
want my own room I've never thought
about that like okay we know we're doing
I was feeling we're not gonna get this
done and I I have faith in us what would
you do if I was in the shower and you
needed to use the restaurant hey would
you go number two out of politeness and
the fact that there are the humidity and
possible stench and that's just not a
good combo no yeah I could do pee that's
not a problem so I was dating a guy once
who had the flu and we were living
together and I'm not gonna lie he put
the bed what are you gonna do you help
them you know I like that that's super
nice because I think I would hesitate a
lot things are like bodily functions
everyone yeah if you can't handle them
and you've got some different maturity
issues I thought it's really impressive
that she said this she took care of one
of her exes number two's cuz I don't
think I have the strength if that's
unconditional love I might I might I
don't know I might not have it yeah I
don't know oh well that would that
really escalated pretty quickly
yeah faster I am I'm really trying I
believe in here so um have you ever been
engaged before um not in my eyes uh what
does that mean so I I had someone I was
living with who we were at a party and
we were both really drunk and he asked
me if I would marry him and I was
standing in line for the bathroom and I
was like sure and I went in the bathroom
and it came back out and he had told
people I was gonna marry him
so well you to be fair you did say you
were going to marry him yes but he was
like calling friends and family I think
this is I think fine work I think it is
more like in like an installation piece
kind of like we look at this off in the
corner of our house and think about the
day we moved in together and it's kind
of like meaningful in that way or we
just finish it later do we though that's
the question yes also you you would want
to finish this yes I got you okay
I would like even if we had to be
somewhere in five minutes I'd be like
we're fixing this when we get back or
even if you went like went home and
passed out so this is the living room at
like 1:00 in the morning like this is
gonna bug you if this is undone yes
because someone might step in and then
it's an insurance liability the couple
is getting married they have $100,000 to
plan a wedding if they can't agree on
how to spend their money in ten minutes
they win no advantage for the final
stage they lost the last challenge and
did not receive an extra twenty thousand
dollars how much is this worth I think
it's just us voting okay
so just to clarify this is my day yeah
no I don't know I don't believe that I
think that's super I initially made a
joke that it was my day and he kind of
went with it when it came to the
marriage he was kind of a pushover I
wouldn't want someone to just do what I
want to do just because I wanted it and
because I said something like that I'm
I'm gonna let my wife do whatever she
wants I don't know I just want my wife
to be happy whatever we're doing okay
yeah that's legit I'm gluten-free so I
don't give a [ __ ] about cake flours
important to you
yeah décor matters can we have weed and
fused Buffett yeah whatever you want 50
person guests wedding or a hundred fifty
I'm one of seven kids so hundred so what
are we gonna do with our last five grand
I vote we keep the five grand yeah let's
do it let's go to Mexico to do some
drugs I mean do we just mix the whole
wedding and a loaf see that's really my
energy right I'm more of like can we
just like throw it out and just go to
the forest and like bring like six
people and like a weird dude you want to
get married in the woods
and dress up like elves that's fine well
it should be a group decision for sure
so we're keeping all this work
destination destination weird wedding
the forest of some kind
we have 10k to do with afterward for an
ayahuasca ceremony in which all of our
guests what is it I've never heard of
that
that's where I would draw the line with
my wife we're not inviting our friends
to come in the forest with us on our
wedding day
[Music]
almost as scary you've been here before
no I haven't not with a ring yeah with
the ring not for real man um sure yes I
do
oh sweet oh wait I'm supposed to give
you a ring too oh yeah do you accept
this token of my non never-ending
affection will you marry me yeah of
course
okay come I got you no sorry Tommy
didn't want a kiss I'm not gonna live
Bose was pretty romantic maybe part of
me got caught up in the moment there and
I was like if that's your wife she's
kiss all right but then I'm like it's
not your wife so are we gonna have a
baby can we adopt I think we should I
think we should I think that'll become
clear in the next part why we should the
couple must name and agree on how to
raise their new child because they
received the last advantage a babysitter
will come take care of the baby for five
minutes it's alive I think yes is it
alive so my abs have bounced back really
well but like oh my god do you want to
pick it up or do you know how to pick up
a baby
yeah I know how to pick up a baby okay
well now I'm self-conscious now I'm like
do I know how to pick up a baby okay my
child do you have any preference on
names have you thought about baby names
yeah I'm gonna be honest I'm like a big
Lion King fan anything from The Lion
King would be pretty dope he just went
from being like this kind of like dude
dude to like all of a sudden you can
just see his inner child and him light
up and it was really cute and sweet
imagine being five and watching that
movie you're like holy like it's like
watching I don't know somebody paint the
Sistine Chapel like if you got to be
there when it happened it could be Nala
be Simba Chiara you know like anything
like yours well I think it's like liking
to but there's a sequel how about this
you you take the first name and I'll
take the middle name Henry Henry Mufasa
yeah so do you want me to take it home
of course I don't think I'm doing a very
good job
hey baby carrots suck on my finger shut
up okay this is whatever you want we
have fun did we give it a toy here
please entertain the child Henry you
have such a lovely singing voice to run
away now remember when you sang at our
wedding that was so beautiful yeah you
should sing some more the dinner table
was a no-go I don't know I think I might
be on my phone a little bit when we
started disagreeing on that and the baby
was crying that was probably the most
real part of the whole like we're really
in this like we're stuck if I see a
funny video while I'm sitting at the
dinner table you just want me to wait so
laughter well you wouldn't see the funny
video if your focus is on that well it's
my focus with mostly be on you guys but
I probably just have my phone like down
to the side a little bit and just kind
of like checking if I'm scrolling
through my phone and I find a video
that's really funny and I'll show you a
funny video you're not gonna be like how
dare you check your phone at the table
you're gonna be like oh wow that's the
funny video I'm glad you show that to me
you're at a dinner table where you're
with people you supposedly love that you
have a family I don't think my love is
measured by me checking my phone or not
but my love language is quality time
okay how would you feel if you were
having a special dinner with your kid
he's pulling out his phone while you're
talking to him about
important lengthen you know and then
he'd be like will you do it dad maybe in
a way I'd be proud because I'd be seeing
him mirror some of my own qualities are
those qualities that you want okay baby
does not like us arguing I'm so sorry
I will never check my phone during
dinner Oh babysitter thank you for this
wow I can't believe it's been 17 years
and little Henry Mufasa I went to
college early
he went to Harvard at the age of 14 I'm
so proud of him you raised an amazing
brilliant child I mean you did help so
it was team that was intense
I'm not gonna lie I guess it is weird I
guess I'm sort of emotionally recoiling
now and realizing like how much I just
learned about you in a short period of
time but we could hang out as friends Oh
hard core I'm glad we didn't have sex it
would have ruined it yeah we could be
friends we can be friends we realized we
have stuff in common yeah but it's just
not marriage my dating plans now I'm
going with the flow like a speck of dust
in the wind if you're down to start a
cult I'm quite single I don't think you
need to know everything about a person
on the first date but people change I
don't want to be beholden to something I
thought I was or believed in on the
first date who knows by the end of it
maybe I would be open to ayahuasca maybe
I'm just being I don't know weird about
it right now that's actually the thing
holding me back from true happiness are
you Italian I am I am too oh wow Wow
okay yeah yeah yeah well it was really
dope it was nice meeting you having a
lifetime of love I'm gonna add you on
Instagram oh yeah for sure it does yeah
then you're gonna find out how weird I
really am I'm with it yeah
which way separate ways